[Music]
I was naive enough to believe that I
could do something that people said
couldn't be done but if you really want
to do something new you've got to go
where it's scary while smalll I'm the
president of chromatic technologies we
make the ink that makes the mountains
turn blue when it's cold on the course
like in
[Music]
I'm just a nerd that makes goo that
changes colors you know it to make it
great
I need somebody like Kira Lee hi hi I'm
Carrie hi Carrie I'm Lyle nice to meet
you welcome to CPI kiri Lee Jones and I
have partnered together to bring her
artistic talent and CT eyes color change
cold technology together and create a
unique piece of art and I'm so excited
to see what what'll happen with it
I paint mostly murals so I just always
believe that everything is a canvas I
love to experiment I just always want to
be learning
so kind of what I'm envisioning it for
this big art project is the concept of a
kaleidoscope the kaleidoscope is gonna
go in and out of the colors like you're
looking through a snowflake and these
are all the colors so it'll be
complicated but create an invisible
piece of art that comes to life when you
make it cold so the idea would be we
have this platform here that has a
chilled background to it I've never seen
anything like this no I've never heard
of anything know who would be crazy
enough to do it right yes yes
I am painting a giant refrigerated
aluminum canvas with the colour changing
paint that cools down to be in color and
then when it's at room temperature it's
white so it basically looks like it's
invisible she kept saying it was
invisible and I kept thinking there's no
possible way but yeah no it's definitely
invisible it looks kind of pink in the
night goes away immediately
after hearing Lyle talk about it and
being so specific about the degrees that
I was gonna change I was very confused I
was very confused
my biggest qualms is mixing the colors
and not being able to see it so I'm
interested to see if all the colors see
I will know 190 degrees
[Music]
all the colors are showing up it reacts
with the cold like pretty quickly so
it's very easy now just your painting
which is cool hi how are you I'm great
that is beautiful so it's supposed to
look like a kaleidoscope so when it
starts to cool down you'll start to see
all the changing colors and all of the
things coming nice all right so let's
check this out here oh wow it's crazy
it's like I'm discovering the piece as
I'm spraying it yeah I mean I had no
idea all this stuff was in here I'm
discovering that I forgot to put green
paint right there I want everyone like
be seeing in front of it and like
literally feel like that exhale of
coldness as it like rushes over them I
hope that when they see it they get the
sense that something magicals happen
[Music]